pourquoi est ce que c'est important de
connaître enfin dans l'espoir qu'on
puisse le cas d'être l'origine de sarov
deux boys là pour éviter sascoc trois
peut-être parce que c'est quand même
comprendre d'où vient cette pandémie
s'est évité la prochaine et comme je
vous le disais les virus qui viennent la
nature c'est ça existe mais il n'a pas
tant que ça en fait qui qui sont venus
naturellement par la faune sauvage qui
ont fait des pandémies comme ça et celle
ci s'est presque presque une première
avec un tel impact
et si elle vient de laboratoire ben
c'est quand même important de le savoir
parce que si on avait évité de faire ça
ou si on l'avait fait de façon plus
précautionneuse n'y aurait pas eu la
pandémie et si ça vient des animaux
c'est important aussi de le savoir pour
savoir par quels animaux sont passés par
qu'est l'élevage pour contrôler ces
élevages pour qu'on vous tenez le
circuit en fait que le circuit viennent
du laboratoire ou qui viennent de la
faune sauvage via les élevages c'est
important de le comprendre pour éviter
que l'aide d'autres virus reprennent le
même chemin en fait
[Musique]